uh hi I'm Jonathan Walker I just
speak hi I'm Jonathan Walker am I
supposed to have a mic you want all
right there we go let's go you can all
hear me I take it I'm a third-year
doctoral student here I'll be uh
introducing tonight's speaker uh the the
talk tonight is part of the Harold Roode
Memorial lecture series uh so I'll say a
few words first about Harold Roode uh
Professor Harold Roode was a teacher
mentor and friend to many generations of
students of government history and
international relations he served as a
heavy machine gunner and radio operator
during World War II in Patton's thirdd
Army and continued his military service
in the Army Reserve during the Korean
War as an order of battle specialist and
a strategic intelligence analyst he also
served on the staff and faculty of the
sixth Army intelligence School Dr Roode
earned his ba and his PhD in political
science from the University of Califoria
California Berkeley and began teaching
in 1962 at Claremont men's college now
Claremont McKenna College where he
became the WM kek Foundation professor
of international strategic studies uh so
the lecture tonight is the third
installment uh in the herald rude
lecture series uh given by students of
Dr Roode and the speaker is uh Steven
cambone uh Dr cambone is the founder of
aurc advisers LLC he serves on the
boards of the Rumsfeld
Foundation very generous organization
and several early stage and startup
companies from 2007 to 2012 he held
senior corporate positions at connetic
North America he served in the George W
Bush Administration as the second
ranking Department of Defense policy
official and as the first under
secretary of defense
policy during the90s he served on
several congressionally mandated
commissions one on ballistic missile
threats the United States and the other
on the organization and management of
the space assets of the United States he
was a senior fellow at the center for
strategic international studies and the
director of research at The Institute
for National Security studies at the
National Defense University he earned
his ba at Catholic University and his Ma
and PhD from Claremont Graduate School
where among other great professors he
studied with Dr Harold rude uh his talk
tonight is anticipating history how well
can China control its destiny
uh please join me in welcoming Dr
Cambo well thank you everyone it's a
pleasure to be here uh Dr Craig reminds
me that this is my second time here uh
the first time was so long ago that I
embarrass to admit I vaguely recommend
remember having come down um and and
that was because in the uh in the late
80s um there was so so much going on uh
in my own uh world of of things that uh
um my wife will attest that I missed
most of the second half of the 80s so my
apologies Nikki for not having recalled
the last time I was I was with all of
you I do remember the stories he told
however I just couldn't place them in
time so that may be a function of
age um and I'm I'm beginning to to think
that uh any of the uh the uh iies for
poor memory that are being invented
these days it's time for me to start
um so each of us who have had the
privilege of attending even one of Dr
rud's classes has an indelible
impression of a slight wispy haired
softspoken gentleman teaching us about
the hard realities of life as they were
made manifest in the relations among
nations uh Dr JD Crouch uh and Dr Chris
Harmon um who were delivered the first
and second uh Roode
lectures um have if any of you attended
those lectures recalled for you Dr Roode
in in Vivid tones and so I'm not going
to spend much time on on Professor
roode's personality and and his uh his
way of uh commanding the
classroom um but I will I I do want to
focus uh on on how it is that he made of
himself arguably one of the most
influential and again arguably least
well-known at least outside a circle of
colleagues and students uh teacher of
statesmanship so we want to focus a bit
on that question of
statesmanship and in making the
assertion about his being most
influential and not very well known I
include in that Circle um those who
study and practice in whole or in part
the Arts of molding and shaping the
character of citizens creating Andor
defending the nation and the state and
and and teaching about how to govern in
ways best suited to assure the
well-being of and fairness if not
justice but fairness uh for the
Govern Dr rud's students uh have taught
and and led universities and colleges Dr
AR uh was one of his
students uh they have done that uh with
distinction uh teaching successive
generations Little about what they
should think and a great deal about how
to think and Dr roots students have
served in the public domain with
distinction as well leading foundations
and nonprofit organizations and in the
legislative and executive branches and
agencies of government uh both at the
state and uh National level and it's
noteworthy that the branches of the rude
uh genealogy from which these students
have evolved events similarities in
temperament uh thoughtfulness patience
and determination of the original root
stock of of Dr Rood himself there are
students from uh Claremont uh USC
Missouri State here at Hillsdale Dallas
isua ashin Villanova Michigan State the
list goes on who when they meet one
another even had they not previously met
instantly recognizing each other the
influence of Professor Roode in their
principles and
practices now as easily as he expressed
himself in the
classroom um Dr Roode was in nearly the
same measure resistant to putting his
thoughts into
writing those of us who witnessed it
will never forget and will always be
grateful to Dr Harry Jaffa some of you
have heard of and may have met Professor
joh for badgering Dr Roode into writing
his only book length publication
entitled kingdoms of the Blind and um
it's still around and you can probably
find it here in the Hillsdale Library I
suspect and apart from kingdoms of the
blind a prize-winning essay he he wrote
for the naval US Naval Institute back in
the late 60s called distant ramparts and
a small number of other texts Dr Rue did
not leave much uh behind that's broadly
available in the public prints that was
written in his own hand and for that
reason we're also grateful to uh to Dr
Crouch and to another party who is um
responsible for putting these lectures
together Dr Pat gy who was down at the
University of
Virginia uh for putting together a book
that they just recently published on Dr
roode's uh teaching
called entitled rather you run the show
or the show runs
you and and that was one of Dr roode's
uh frequent Expressions as a way of
trying to encapsulate um for us um his
understanding of of the essence of
international relations again the title
of the book you run the show where the
show runs
you so let me go to Dr Root's thought
um he had the view that international
relations are
unforgiving simply and utterly
unforgiving he opens kingdoms of the
blind in the following
way it is not a defect to pray for peace
and to hope there will be no war but
those who predict War have statistics on
their side those who predict Everlasting
peace are always wrong Nations who are
comfortable in the status quo prefer
peace those that would overset the
status quo to establish a new order in
the world will resort to force if it is
within their capability to do so
violence and force are intrinsic to
Revolution even as they are to good
order now we published Kingdoms in 1977
but L we think that Dr roode's warning
against the tendency particularly of
liberal democracies to deny the
probability of war is anachronistic that
is to say A View from 1977 is it
applicable today I'd suggest we uh we
think about the world in our own time we
have terrorism and War rif in the Middle
East we have the difficulties with Iran
Russia and China all of whom are looking
to alter their circumstances in this
world and the US government divided uh
and polarized while permitting its
foreign and defense policies and actions
to be constrained by a budget
sequestration all of those things cause
us to do well to heed the conclusion of
Dr roode's book now remember he starts
by saying war is never um he concludes
it in in the following way conceding
that he did not MN of war with the hope
of being right to the contrary he made
clear that he was willing to suffer the
indignity of being called foolish if war
did not occur but after examining the
indications that ought to give rise to
preparations for war on the part of the
United States he concluded his book as
follows if the West prepares for war and
no war comes
we may enjoy the freedom of criticizing
ourselves for our
foolishness if War comes and the West is
unprepared not merely to fight but to
win then there can be no greater
Folly now Professor you Roode used a
number of techniques to develop and
present his teaching and I propose this
evening to employ two of them the
Contemporary press
account he always walked around with a
sheath of clippings from newspapers some
of which went back to the 1930s and some
of which were as fresh as the day that
day of class okay but he always had a
whole bunch of whom under arm so
contemporary press accounts and enduring
Concepts that were that related to the
development consolidation and employment
of Power by the
state the latter uh he left for
Discovery to his students through the
use of of a list of of terms places or
events he would hand each of us a list
at the beginning of a semester about 50
of these terms uh places or events each
of us getting a different list and he
expected us over the course of the
semester to find describe Define or
explain what was
important about those terms places or
events and many of us I being one did
not get very far through the list and
quite honestly most of what I found was
probably
wrong
um now if we were going to do an
international relations class with Dr
Roode on the question of China which is
our subject for this evening he might
have put three of these terms on that
list one would be the 10 great commands
I'm sorry Camp
campaigns a second might be George
III and the last might be something
called Jim
haa and you'd sort of get this as part
of your list and you'd say China T great
can campaigns George III what am I
supposed to do with this well in the
spirit of the evening and an
acknowledgement that he was the rude the
master of this kind of an approach I'd
like to apply his technique of using
terms to to shed some light on the
subject we have before us and that is
China and whether in reading the
newspapers or more aptly today the wide
array of digital material available to
us we can learn enough to anticipate its
history looking out over the next uh 10
to 15 15 years or so and ask ourselves
three
questions can China run its domestic
show right if we can't run our domestic
affairs the opportunity to run
International Affairs is pretty small so
can it run its domestic show and given
the answer to that question can it run
the show on the international stage and
thirdly how might we know whether it's
giving direction to the show or whether
a script is being written for it by
others okay so that's the flip side of
it right because if you're not running
the show somebody else is and that means
they're running they're writing their
script for you so where do we place
China on on that on on those on those
two polls so let's apply the uh the
rudian method here
um the work he asked the students to do
on their list was less about the
specific items than it was meant to
introduce them to the essence of what he
had learned and what he thought about
human action and purpose government and
governing the building in defense of the
state and how all of it might be
affected by enduring factors over which
man has no control such as geography
where were you born where do you live
which way do the rivers flow how high
are the mountains what is the rain due
to your to your livelihood and the like
but as focused as he was in
international relations Dr Roode also
taught about what he called
constitutionalism that is the creation
of government the Arts of governing the
building and the defense of the
state and and in and it's and it is from
this perspective that I'd like to
explore the questions I've just raised
about China can it run its own Affairs
can it run the international Affairs and
who's writing the script so let me give
you here three different terms to
introduce us to some of the issues that
we might want to think
about Roman Road
building
coinage and the sank
ports they're about as obscure aren't
they with respect to China is the first
three I gave you so I felt pretty good
about that it took me a while to find
these three but I I felt pretty good in
finding them so let's talk about Road
Building look at that it
worked Road
building uh throughout history has been
about binding the disperate possessions
of a state into a cohesive whole and
that was as
true the most true of any uh was
Rome it is true that all Rome roads did
lead to Rome but of equal or greater
importance was that all Rose LED from
the seed of power to the sources of the
Empire's power its people agricultural
products Commodities tax revenues and
more and provided the means of governing
could be created deployed and employed
by the state those in the provinces and
the riches they represented would
continue to look and travel to Rome for
reward and more importantly for
Honor these were significant Investments
a road is estimated to have cost about a
million dollar a mile for some 55,000 M
of road which were constructed over the
life of the Empire 55,000 miles that's a
lot the role of this infrastructure in
building and cementing the Roman rule
and the strength of the Empire is is
well
established travel from London to Rome
for example uh approximately 1200 miles
took about 60 days if you went by sea it
took about 30 right so you went sea
connected to the roads you could get to
Rome in about 30 days and the lower the
figure on the lower right hand side
gives you some idea of the time lapses
so those those squiggly lines are days
being measured from the uh the center of
Rome now by comparison in the United
States in
1800 it took by horseback from New York
City to the vicinity of what is today St
Louis about 1,000 miles something on the
order of 30 to 45
days a trip from New York City to New
Orleans by Sea Under sale took somewhere
on the order of a month in 1800 so the
accomplishment of the
Romans by contrast was quite significant
right they they bound an empire together
by way of
roads now China fully appreciates the
value of infrastructure development one
estimate suggests that it will spend
nearly $4
trillion between 05 2005 and 2030 or
about 10% of the global Global projected
total of infrastructure spending in the
world okay this is for roads aqueducts
railroads
right and in addition to its Urban
infrastructure the Chinese invest
heavily in the road rail pipe pipelines
water projects the uh the national
highway system is going to cost them
about
$240 billion by
2020 they plan to spend about 300
billion on High-Speed Rail projects s
during the first decade of this century
and it turns out um you know because
life is good today's newspaper there's a
supplement in the Washington
Post uh which details for you the effort
being made by the Chinese to be to build
highspeed rail throughout the country
what they're willing to spend and and
what they expect to get as a result of
that investment in tying together the
coast with the the inner part of the
country and the uh nor North with the
South and in fact the statistics that
the Chinese pull out are in fact
measured by east to west and north to
south they understand the importance of
that infrastructure in tying together
their
country but as the uh the Romans did uh
before
them um it's also designed this
infrastructure to extend its influence
to its
periphery China now has five of the top
10 and seven of the top 15 container
ports and it's not intent to remain at
home with its shipping its companies are
investing in ports in Bangladesh Sri
Lanka Pakistan East Africa Greece Brazil
West Africa roddam P Panama Seattle and
Los Angeles to name just a few okay and
by the way it's looking to finance the
building of a new uh Central American
Canal along the of considered route
through Nicaragua this is all
infrastructure spending okay and you
look at it you say that's just
infrastructure but if we go back and
remember right how the Romans used
infrastru structure and think about how
we here in the United States have used
infrastructure uh one could argue that
there is uh some plan
here but they've made Investments to
extend their Road and Rail lines to
Western China and from there all the way
to Western Europe with termin in Germany
and Spain and Spurs to Moscow and South
through Iran Pakistan India and into
southeast
Asia they're making extraordinary loans
for bringing Central Asian oil and gas
into China consumer goods from China to
Central as
Asia and if that weren't sufficient that
is to say its penetration into uh the
central U Asian uh land mass and oh by
the way into the South China seas and
and all the
rest the Chinese have also made them of
themselves observers on the Atlant
Arctic Council by way of preserving for
themselves the opportunity to open
Passage through the Arctic as the ice
melts for Chinese Goods cutting the time
it takes to get from China to Europe uh
nearly in half as opposed to going all
the way around through the Indian Ocean
and up through the Panama Canal and on
into uh the
Mediterranean all of this effort aims to
make China the center of a Global
Network of surface and Seaborn Transit
supported by a domestic infrastructure
able to efficiently manufacture and
transport inter internally the raw
semi-finished and finished products that
make up the global supply chain and we
have not even touched upon its
investments in IT services steel cement
ship building automobile manufacturing
Aerospace coal natural gas extraction
and other
Industries infrastructure let's talk
about
coinage coinage is here represented by
an English Noble up there in the upper
uh right hand corner it was first issued
by the Royal Mint of Edward III now the
Royal Mint continues to provide currency
at the direction of Her Majesty's
treasury uh now
coins were originally uh not currency
but actual
money they they had the thing itself had
value um and that's still the case the
thing down on the lower left hand side
is called the Royal mans and it's still
in C circulation but as trade became
commonplace and the need to trade to
replace barter with transactions
involving some more uh portable form of
of money States became the States became
the source either of the coins
themselves or as in the case of England
both the mint and the guarantor of the
value ascribed to the coin even those it
minted for others by the way and they
and the state began to guarantee the
weight and standard established for that
coin indeed they're involved an entire
ceremony still follow today for example
in Britain for assuring that a coin met
the weight and standard established for
it it's called The Trial of the pcks
another perfectly rudyan term toh to add
to the sheet but that thing down on the
bottom there the mans is made out of
platinum and there is an entire process
they go through to assure that that
thing actually contains the amount of of
platinum it's supposed to contain at the
right uh
proportions now as time changed uh trade
became uh more increasingly complicated
but there was one constant the role of
government in affecting the value of
money the currency uh which was based on
it and eventually the direct supply of
the currency itself but in addition the
state came to establish and enforce
contracts associated with property and
trade markets and regul ation related to
the Import and Export of money and
currency as well as goods and services
now the US domestic and international
economy where we participate in today
may be viewed as the epitome of this
Evolution both are based on the dollar
that is the US domestic International
economy which is in reality the dollar
as an IOU issued by a bank chartered by
the US government which establishes the
bearer to obtain from the US government
the face value of the currency on demand
it's treated as legal tender by the
United States and derives its value from
being used in meeting obligations owed
to the United States or to us persons
individuals or corporations I me for a
wide variety of reasons the post World
War II International economy came to be
based on the American dollar now there's
a lot to be said about the dollar
economy
International some will tell you that
it's not a very good thing for the
dollar to be the basis of the
international economy witnessed today
the chatter in the papers about the the
uh increasing value of the American
dollar and its effect on American
industry for example um right the more
expensive a dollar gets the harder it is
for foreigners to buy things right sure
it's easier for us to buy things from
others but buying things from others
isn't what makes the economy go selling
things to others is what makes the
economy go um now uh the Chinese have
not failed to observe how important
important it is to have your currency as
the centerpiece of the international
economy um they understand that it gives
that the dollar uh the dollar standing
gives the US considerable uh influence
and leverage on the international
economy and China is working hard to
increase its own leverage on that
International economy and so as you've
been following in the Press um China has
founded the Asian infrastructure
investment bank right to which the
United States insisted that its allies
not participate and which the English
now followed by others have decided they
will participate in this bank and the
Chinese while they invited the United
States to play did not make it
hospitable place for the United States
to participate and so what we have now
is a challenge from the Chinese via the
Asian International in infrastructure
Investment Bank to the World Bank to the
IMF and to other
International institutions which the
United States was at the heart of
founding and continues to lead in its
governments and the Chinese quite
frankly don't care for it they think
it's time for the rest of us to
recognize the place of China in the
international economy and one has to
admit they have a point so they have
gone out and created this Bank along
with at least three others that are
designed to begin to
Leverage The International system uh in
the directions that they would like to
see it
go now I would argue that it' be a
mistake to conclude that China's
policies that is to say the creation of
these Banks the manipulation of its own
currency the ways in which it manages
its trade the mercantilistic policies it
follows the sometimes exploitive
activities in Africa and other places
all of which one can point to but it' be
a mistake to conclude that those
policies are being driven that its
policies overall are being driven by its
economics right it might be more
accurate to say that its Ambitions to
restore its place in the International
System a place it contends was unjustly
taken from it by the West in the mid
19th century and and which resulted in
its sense of humiliation for more than a
century are made possible by China's
purposeful development of its economy so
so the argument i' leave you with is
they're not being driven by their
economy to do certain things they're
they're they're making their economy do
certain things so that they can gain
leverage in the International System
there's a difference between those
two all right so let's turn to the sank
points ports um what are they about
they're about Sovereign prerogative more
specifically they represented a grant of
protection and privilege by The
Sovereign to his subjects in return for
services to be rendered by them on the
call of the Sovereign but more broadly
it represented the concept of a compact
in which ruler and rules reached an
accommodation both thought fair and
binding that is if either failed to
deliver what had been pledged the other
had grounds for complaint and the right
to the limit of its power of compelling
compliance or extracting by force what
it was
owed now a similar notion of a compact
now so so what was the point of this the
point of this is that these people had
ships the threat to England from across
the ocean or across the English Channel
more or less pass pass by where these
people had their ships so the king said
look I'll let you be able to run your
life down here in your little hamlets
within certain limits as long as when
the French or the Spanish or the Dutch
or the Norse or anybody else shows up
you bring your ships and fight for me
right that that was a deal and by the
way it stayed in place for the better
part of 500 years which was an
interesting
Arrangement
um now this issue of compelling right um
we want to offer talk about the Magna
Carta and how it's the first document
you know in this long history of
bringing us uh liberal traditions and
all the rest if you read it closely what
it really does is what I've said which
is the two sides uh stood there in the
muddy fields of runny me looked each
other in the eye and said look we each
have about this much
power okay and I can compel this and you
can compel that so why don't we agree
that in so far as each of us can compel
each other we will'll agree not to
disagree
okay that that's essentially if you read
through it what it
says now over time it evolves and and
things change but at its heart it was
about a relationship of power between
the Nobles and the King all right which
over time eventually the uh The King The
Sovereign gives way but I'll I'll remind
you going back to the mans right the
head of that
coin is Elizabeth she is still The
Sovereign of Great
Britain not the people of Britain the
queen and they can still compel her to
do things but she is still the queen so
it's an interesting an interesting
observation about what the impact of
these sorts of compacts are over time
now a compact is at the heart of of
Chinese governance as well but it
differs from that of kings in the west
who claim their sovereignty by strict
hereditary heredity divine right or both
in either case the sovereign's Authority
and The Obedience of his subjects were
Beyond question a king's obligations
relative to his subjects however were
for him to calculate hence we end up
with the Magna Carta right John
miscalculated Charters it should be
noticed were the result of offsetting
power not a mutual recognition of right
and obligation now the Chinese dynasty
leadership differs in the source of its
lead legitimacy it is observed to enjoy
what they call the Mandate of Heaven
provided that it Fosters and protects
and is seen to do so by the people what
they call the harmony of society that
Harmony in turn was a function of a
compact of sorts between the court and
the people the emperor had an explicit
duty to provide the people with safety
from social disruption War famine
natural
disaster and to minimize the burdens
imposed by and the corruption of the
emperor himself or his
functionaries in return for obedience
and compliance with the local
administration of the Court's
Representatives um now those
representatives were trained in the
Confucian tradition and the Arts of
administration and were so far as it is
possible to imagine impartial
administrators of law until of course
they became
corrupt now if that compact broke down
in the face of War famine corruption or
other abuses Harmony was lost as was the
mandate to rule and breakdown uh those
dynasties did with cyclical frequency
you notice they last about two 300 years
the
dynasty um and and they go away in a
very unpleasant way mostly through
Rebellion War and the death of a lot of
people now the leadership of China
through the Chinese Communist party is
reminiscent of accepting the differences
in detail the dynastic courts its
legitimacy such as it is
rest not on a Mandate of Heaven to be
sure but on its ability to maintain its
preeminence by managing the Affairs of
the Chinese people while meeting the
needs of
society it's not for nothing that The
Heirs of the 49 Revolution and others
associated with them are known as
princelings nor is it for nothing that
China's president XII ping has taken to
explicitly evoking the wisdom of the
Imperial ages as he seeks to consolidate
his hold on power ensue the disruptive
effects of the forced modernization
policy he himself has
accelerated some would say that the
objection uh uh the objective of the uh
Reform movement underway what they call
the the establishment of the of the rule
of
law uh is is what we are seeking to
accomp what they are seeking to
accomplish in
China but I think a better way to think
about it is rule by law
right it's changed the preposition it's
not the rule of law it's the rule by law
because by making that change what you
do is you acknowledge that the Communist
Party of China is in fact the rulle
making body and is with respect to its
rules and law uh that uh uh political
Society is to be regulated and run so it
is their way that is to say the
promotion of the rule bylaw of promoting
the authority of the um of the Communist
party now the difficulty they have um is
that there the Communist party cadres is
that there can be nothing disinterested
in their rule even at the local levels
okay because the way that the Communist
party is set up and the economy is set
up the local cadr are responsible for
providing for the well-being of the
local populations which means in the end
providing for their own continued
rule uh and there therefore they are
stuck with this problem of having at one
and the same time to keep the economy
improving in order to stay in their
positions of
authority right they they
can't by tradition and history a decline
in the well-being of people means nearly
by definition the failure of legitimacy
of the ruling entity therefore you find
yourself in the position in order to
maintain your legitimacy and Rule
continuing to approve the economy okay
so that's the problem that they have set
for themselves in this compact
relationship that they have made uh with
the Chinese
people so let's turn to this question of
anticipating
history and and use the economy as a
point for stepping
off um we've been trying to lay the
predicate that China has as have States
through history uh used its uh ability
to tax spend mint currency make internal
improvements manage and direct external
trade and investment and maintain a
monopoly on political power and violence
to reshape its domestic and foreign
circumstances in the nearly 40 years
since ding shaoang launched the ongoing
still ongoing Reform movement the growth
in China's capacity to manage its own
Affairs and to modernize its country has
been absolutely
breathtaking um its
economy these charts may be hard to read
but but let me just sort of sketch it
for you it will have a GDP that will
have gone from some $130 billion in 1981
to nearly 10
trillion by
2015 and within that economy per capita
income will have grown to more than from
to more than $3,500 ahead um from less
than
$250 in 1981 and the poverty rate will
have fallen from more than
80% to about 10% by 2010 and if you look
at the chart on your left right that is
an absolutely breathtaking
accomplishment by any measure okay and
there are some comparisons there for
other countries for you to look
at and the Chinese middle class has
grown from practically non-existent 20
years ago to roughly half the total
population the total population I'll
remind you is 1.3 billion people the
middle class in China take for the
except for the moment the differences in
standards and all the rest but a middle
class as it is understood in China is
today twice the size of the population
of the United
States but only half the total
population of
China so you begin to get a sense of the
magnitude of the accomplishment of what
they have done okay this is this is good
stuff now China's success is the result
of a calculated policy as I suggested
earlier follow very rigorously though
flexibly adapted to circumstances is
that emphasize growth by means of
enforced savings remember this is a
communist uh country enforced savings to
generate High investment rates to
underwrite an export oriented economy
that depended on inexpensive and surplus
labor to gain an advantage in prices in
the global
market okay that that's what they did
they said look we can crack this code we
got more people than we can stand we we
can pull enough money out of the economy
to invest in the factories that make the
cheap clothes that everybody's going to
buy and over time they move from making
cheap shoes to making cheap electronics
to now making more sophisticated electri
but the underlying theory of the economy
has remained the same
okay now the formula is not new it's
been tried and found effective uh
throughout Asia in the 80s and the90s
but growth generated by the formula has
not been sustainable in historical
experience so what you see here is a
chart that outlines from Time Zero it
it's it's not by date but it's by
interval of time that every one of those
economies eventually falls off this high
level of
investment right because you just can't
sustain high levels of investment
indefinitely because the underlying and
and and integral factors of the economy
begin to prevent you from doing that
okay um and and so what what happens is
there there is this thing that arises
that people have been able to
identify that's called the uh the middle
income trap and the chart's got a lot of
theory on it and all the rest but what
it really says is at a certain point you
either run out of cheap
labor uh excess investment or you
saturate the
market okay and once you do those things
you just can't keep going all right now
there's some debate about whether this
is a iron LW La of Economics or it is a
um a set of factors which are ephemeral
and come to pass but it is observable
that any number of countries have gone
through this and it is equally
observable what it takes to get out of
it right and you see that listed here on
the right side of the chart right which
is you've got to get productivity up to
offset your wage increases so so for
every time it cost me another dollar to
hire somebody I got to get more
productivity out of them else I'm losing
ground right if productivity stays the
same and cost goes up what what goes
what happens to profit disappears right
so you got to get more productivity you
got to educate people to get what that's
called the knowledge economy and you got
to master
Innovation right and you have to reduce
Reliance on processing export what does
that mean what do the Chinese do how do
they make their living they brought in
the piece Parts they assembled them and
then they shipped them back
out right so the iconic example is the
iPhone right for which their value ad in
the in the production of an iPhone is
Pennies on the
dollar okay because the designs are here
the parts are made elsewhere they bring
them in they assemble them and they ship
them far cheaper than anybody can but
their actual value derived is quite low
so how do you get to the point where you
design the iPhone you produce the
component parts you also assemble it and
you send it out right or you reverse the
flow you send the peace Parts out for
others to do the processing and you reap
the rewards either way it'll work but
continuing on the same path is probably
not going to get them
there
now China has indisputably uh exhausted
cheap
labor um and exports no longer suffice
to meet its growth targets and the CCP
is painfully aware of its circumstance
and it's responding by seeking to quote
unquote rebalance its economy and that
means shifting from an investment to a
consumption-led economy and the gap
between the two though that is between
consumption and
investment is
staggering and that has to be changed so
if you look at the charts uh the one
line shows the level of investment in
the
economy which is uh I think the red line
right so here's Capital formation
here uh consumption is here this is
2,000 and you can see that investment is
driving out consumption I mean you got
only a dollar you got to do something
with it can't spend it
twice right so so they have got
themselves in a situation where they're
spending near to 50% 48 that depends on
when you take the measurements somewhere
between 47 to 50% of the GDP is a result
of investment if you're going to get to
some kind of balance which you see over
there on the
side the
charitable the charitable estimates are
that it's going to take them well into
the next decade before they begin to get
to that point of
rebalancing but to get there you can't
leave the country socioeconomically the
way that it is so what you what you want
to do sorry here's an in in an
intermediate chart by way of comparison
to the United States we're above 70% of
consumption okay now I'm not arguing 70%
is the right number but by way of
comparison with the Chinese you can see
the radical difference between the two
economies okay that's by way of
comparison not by way of a of an
argument about which is
better um but but in order to get to the
rebalancing one of those features that
one has to change is a socioeconomic
circumstances of the country and that
means moving people into
cities why do you want to move people
into cities the densification of the
population increases the rate at which
economic interactions take
place okay um you know uh Starbucks does
not exist in a country that is a rural
economy it it's just it ain't going to
work right you need people you need foot
traffic you need lots of folks going
around and as a general proposition that
is true for most of these most of those
economies and so you can see here um the
chart on the lower right shows you the
kind of GDP growth you get as the
percentage of the population moves into
cities so that's historical example the
Chinese understand it they're tracking
to the same
line and what they will do in order to
get to their their population to a level
that is a at the lower threshold of what
they need to do is that they will move
uh some 250 to to 300 million people
over the next 8 to 10 years into
cities put another way they will move
roughly the population of the United
States from
rural farms and Villages into cities uh
in order to get the density they need to
drive the change in the economy that
they're going to have to get so at a
very high level the Chinese problem can
be summarized as follows its growth to
date is a function of
investment that's the blue I think is
the big blue bar right uh lots of
investment and investment now has
saturated the economy is no longer going
to return the kind of uh uh growth
commensurate with the
cost now you're all economists I know
and certainly I'm not but here here's
here's how you read this chart if these
bars are going up that's bad
and the bars are going up okay and if
you look down in the lower right hand
corner what you see in the period
between 91 and 2011 they got roughly
3.9 things back for every one thing they
put in okay they're now at
five okay that's not the direction you
want to
go this means that your your cost the
investment you are making is returning
less with each dollar each one on that
you put in and therefore you got to go
to consumption to drive the economy to
to uh generate the kind of growth that
you're going to need so that's going to
require that consumption take over for
investment as I
said um but the more interesting thing
is that consumption relative to
investment all else being equal
generates far less return than does
investment so for each dollar I spend
Buy in Starbucks as opposed to a dollar
I spend building a steel factory
assuming there are people to buy my
steel I make more money investing in
steel than I do in Starbucks
okay that that's sort of the simple uh
explanation of this but they have to
make that shift and on on the base of
1.3 billion people buying Starbucks
that's not bad right so if they can get
it done it it it will uh be quite a feet
but it's going to be hard so the other
thing we talked about was total Factor
productivity and again uh this is not a
test the yellow bar shows you what they
have gotten as a relative portion of
their GDP growth out of total Factor
productivity and that's the percentages
down here okay that number here is a
function in 2007 and six and seven that
big jump is finally realizing uh all of
the goodness from all of the investment
they had made in all those previous
years doing better what everybody else
did in making shoes iPads iPods toaster
ovens and God knows what else we bought
from China but by that point they had
maxed out okay and what's total Factor
productivity management skills better uh
processes right all of those things that
are sort of the soft side of making the
economy go so they've maxed out on that
and for them to get to the kind of of uh
of uh total Factor produ tivity that
will take over the
investment uh growth uh is
unachievable it it's never been done in
history so there's no reason to even
begin to think that they're going to be
able to do it
good from from the point of view of
Labor productivity in particular the
Chinese on this curve and you want to be
higher on the curve and above the curve
if you can get there that's where you'd
like to be they live down here on the
wrong side of the curve all the way down
to the bottom and here you see it loone
out for them so the productivity of
their labor per se has never really been
the driver on their
economies and in order to get to a
productive a more productive force in a
service economy which is what's at the
root of a consumption economy means a
very different educational system and a
very different social system than they
have had over the last 50 years okay now
that's not a criticism it's a fact okay
you you got to make those adjustments in
order to be able to be be
successful and there's more in labor
productivity we don't have to to uh to
belabor that so when you see that the U
you make this change the economies I
showed you earlier where you saw the dip
in the investment curve well this is the
drop in the following 10 years in their
GDP all right as they have made that
shift so you you and this is by
percentage point so if your economy was
growing you know at uh at these kinds of
rates you you can see It'll Fall by some
60% to something on the order of
40% so if you have an economy growing at
10% a year and it drops by uh
40% that's what um six 6.4 10 six six%
right that's a big number if you're
growing at 10 12% which is what they
were doing at their Peak and you drop at
six you get to about
6% five six
7% um which is where the Chinese are
headed
okay so these are the numbers as they
have begun to come out uh the Asia
Development Bank issued its view today
that the Chinese would stay at about 7%
the consensus though in the rest of the
world is that they're dropping and and
could drop
as you see here the conference board has
them in the first five years the next
decade down below 4% a year in growth
now that's better than we're doing we're
struggling to to to to stay above
two okay so this is not bad performance
in the
absolute but if you're trying to support
the transition of the economy we just
talked about if you're trying to have
enough money in people's pockets to go
to Starbucks and if you're oh by the way
going to leave enough money in their
pockets to pay for their old mothers
their old fathers their older
grandfathers and grandmothers and oh by
the way educate their kids provide for
their own Social Security and manage
their lives as that new middle class we
talked about
before 4% is probably not enough which
is why there is a certain amount of hand
ringing taking
place uh within the uh the ch Chinese
party um Communist party as time goes on
uh this is a graphic representation of
how you might see those numbers change
um and here what we see is I'm sorry U
how much time it takes to actually get
that rebalancing done so for the
Japanese um their growth spurt you see
here for the Chinese to get to the point
where they can balance out their economy
maybe from the years of expansion which
for the Chinese date to roughly you can
take your pick you can go to 1979 you
can go to 1990 go to 2000 take your pick
it's going to take a long
time so what that suggests is that they
have a struggle ahead of them that is
nothing compared to what they to the
Free Ride essentially that they have had
economically speaking uh over the last
last uh three decades in terms of their
growth this is just meant to say what's
the difference if you grow at one
percentage number as opposed to another
uh and at the high end if you grow at uh
let's say 7 a half% you got a an 80
trillion economy out in the 2030 time
frame uh if you grow at three and a
half% which is not an impossible number
for them uh it's it's roughly half of
that okay
so we're talking big numbers here okay
this is not small potatoes we're talking
about very large numbers all right and
and and overhanging all of this is is
their debt which you may have been
following the papers it's now up above
250% it has grown at a rate three times
the economy over the last uh five years
uh and sooner or later even though most
of that debt is owned by the state
somebody has to pay for it
right somebody has to pay for
it even if it's only the people who now
don't have the wherewithal to pay for
Grandma and Grandpa Mom and Dad the kids
the schooling the house the mortgage
right all those other kinds of things
even though the state keeps rolling over
the bonds if you don't have money in
your pocket you're going to begin to
feel the effect so where does that leave
us um I I think that the uh the Chinese
want to run the show there's no question
question that they do they they talk
about it in ways that are uh
unambiguous uh and and hard not to
credit um when they say um Asia should
look after its own security the United
States has mismanaged the international
economy we're going to form an Asia
infrastructure Investment Bank we China
are the centerpiece of the trade
relationships here in the um Eastern uh
Pacific there's they are unambiguous
about it they are unambiguous about
talking about the changing International
circumstances creating new opportunities
that had never existed before and now is
the time for them to take advant they
they are unabashed in talking about
these
things but at the same time um they have
to be be able to deliver on the the
economic uh
capabilities uh at the same time that
they are trying to
um assert their place uh in the
International System they've got to be
able to sustain themselves at
home so the Chinese have established two
uh Centenary goals um and and again
depending upon how you measure GDP per
capita right um you're going to see a
fluctuation in
numbers sometimes it's 10 sometimes it's
eight that's not important what's
important is the the relative
numbers uh that you see here between and
among these various countries and if you
look at the the performance of China
here the width by the way the bar is the
size of the population relative to the
other bars okay so here's a very big
population with a relatively low per
capita income here's the United States
sitting over here at 50 here's the
Chinese on this particular scale a 10
and who's ahead of them well let's see
uh Egypt South Africa Brazil Mexico
Russia Japan
Germany okay in in terms of per capita
income they're fairly low so they're
looking as one of their Centenary goals
which they would reach in 20 uh 21 which
is the 100th anniversary of
the the Communist party's founding is to
get themselves to roughly $10,000
$133,000 per capita
income okay now what I just just showed
you suggest that that's going to be a a
sporting proposition okay the second
goal is to make themselves a moderately
prosperous society and I'd suggest to
you that that means getting up into this
neighborhood someplace relatively
speaking all right so that there isn't
an underlying unease in the population
if there are um let's say glitches in
the performance of the economy okay I
mean imagine Ma so the Chinese faced
with the the the financial crisis in
2008 pumped billions of dollars we put
in whatever the number was trillion
something they put in no we put 789
billion right wasn't that the number of
tarp something like that they put in
scads more than
that right and they did it if you go
back and look at those investment charts
you see a big spike in 2008 and N they
did it to Stave off any possibility of
there being social unrest as that
International System began to affect the
domestic economy in China they couldn't
stand that proposition and so they spent
a lot of money to put it off as time
goes on the population becomes more
demanding costs go up money gets tighter
this gets harder to do okay now it's not
I'm not here to tell you that they are
on the verge of
collapsing but I am here to say that it
is not going to be easier so what have
they done they have said uh X has that
it is time for us to start talking about
the Chinese dream right Chinese dream
and and that's designed uh to to have
and it has four parts um China needs to
be strong economically politically and
diplomatically right scientifically and
Military it needs to be civilized that
is to say equity and fairness internally
a rich culture High
morals it needs to have ammity among its
social classes and it needs to be have a
healthy environment so those those are
sort of the components of it but not
only is it designed this Chinese dream
for domestic consumption it is designed
to paint for the world the picture of
what can be done by an economy and a
political system like
China's elsewhere in the
world because there are other states
Kazakhstan right Kenya South Africa
Nigeria right start thinking of those
places where you find a great deal of
Chinese interaction and interest
the proposition is this Chinese dream is
adaptable by them for their
circumstances and they too can succeed
just as China has succeeded and if they
follow the Chinese method then they can
uh prosper and China for its part will
find itself as being
the the uh the new leader of the
International System right because it
will have propagated that method by
which people do
well and the definition of leadership is
being able to help others to do well so
the Chinese say look that's how we're
going to go about doing this so they are
laying the root in this in this notion
of the dream both as a way of of telling
the folks look we're on the verge of a
great success here on the one hand and
telling the world that this success of
China is good for you too so don't be
nervous as you watch us grow not an
unreasonable thing for them to
do
but as we suggested a few moments ago
they do have they do have their
difficulties because if you want to
create here's the uh the brics bank the
the the uh Brazilians the Russians and
so forth the uh development Banks uh
this is money currency right these are
all International systems which you see
they have created Shadow organizations
behind uh on the global scene you've got
to have have an economy domestic economy
that is going to be able to support that
kind of behavior in the International
System so you not only have to walk the
walk you gotta you talk the talk you got
to walk the walk okay it's what it boils
down to and for the Chinese they're
coming up on a moment here where it's
going to be increasingly difficult for
them to do so not impossible but
increasingly difficult and therefore one
has to wonder are they going to be able
to run the show to make domestically and
if they and even if they can do they
have enough left over to run it
internationally so what else do you want
to look at well one last thing okay I
said they got to have a a different way
of approaching education they need a
knowledge economy and all the rest that
means you need to have the wherewithal
for people to learn to debate to fight
with one another to argue to disagree
these are the seven NOS I think that
have been uh put out uh recently um they
coincide with some of the events that
have taken place in Hong Kong there is a
massive campaign underway to
suppress uh universities and uh Free
Speech uh there is a uh directive
underway uh to avoid talking about
Western uh institutions and civilization
they are not appropriate for debate in
China okay so there is at the very same
time that they need this burst of energy
and that kind of innovation that comes
from an open Society to help them grow
there is at the same time a clamping
down of the very forces that are likely
to help them do it okay so so again you
see the the kind of contradiction that
lives
inside that economy now let's close
where we
began what were the 10
campaigns nobody here knows do you
terrible terrible I didn't either the 10
campaign
um had to do whoops had to do with um
the efforts in the
1700s uh to essentially settle the
frontier and create borders right the
distinction between Frontiers and
borders being you know a border is a
place we all demarcate and one side and
the other knows where it is and respects
it and enforces it a frontier is where
folks just kind of wash back and forth
without ever sort of recognizing where
they are so this is a campaign against
the zunger
Empire um the only one apparently in
Chinese history where the emperor uh
directed that essentially this whoops uh
this people who lived out here be
exterminated and they
were some 6 700,000 of them after a not
very long period of
time uh couldn't be found
that neighborhood is where the Wagers
live right that is Jing Jang the New
Frontier the place where they are
worried to death about the rise of
Muslim insurgencies and where they are
engaged in a massive Crackdown uh to
prevent there being a Insurrection in
that part of the world they are mortally
afraid of the um uh spread of uh
jihadism from Afghanistan and Pakistan
up into that part of China where they
will lose control so remember I talked
about the roads and reaching out right
what they're worried about is that there
is coming back all right a tital wave of
Muslim Insurrection that puts their
their investment out there and the
legitimacy of the country of the party
rather at
risk and what about George III well it
turns out in 1793 George you know having
lost the colonies decides he's going to
go make his fortune in China sends an
embassy out there to go visit the
emperor the emperor says as you can see
here look
George you're a nice enough guy okay but
you got nothing I
want and you certainly have nothing I
need and if you read this L on I mean
it's just unbelievable he says look if I
let your people come up here are they
really really going to act like
Chinese and if I send my people to you
are you going to treat them with the
dignity they
deserve we can't have this okay and at
this period of time um anybody who was
in Chinese was still referred to as a
barbarian okay now the upshot of this
right
is um eventually the British decide that
um they can get some trade but they're
they are sending massive amounts of
silver into China because it's used as
coins money and there isn't enough of it
in China because there were still 600
million 450 million people at this time
to buy
tea and if you're say wait a minute we
grow this stuff
called
opium which we can trade for
tea hence the origin of the Opium War
hence we end up with uh unequal treaties
hence we end up with a century of
humiliation okay this all begins roughly
1840 1850 and if we think back over our
own history this is about the period of
the American Civil War and all of us can
remember right the implications of that
for the country and what it means the
Chinese do as well they they get it and
they understand what it means to lose
control just like the emperor did to
lose control over their circumstances
and find themselves at the mercy of the
West so those seven NOS are not
surprising right for a for a Communist
party that is looking to maintain
control and
last we talked about the issue of uh of
being able to uh to go out in the world
and uh and the Port City whose name I
can never properly
pronounce it is right over here
it's uh Sri
Lanka and Admiral he uh in 14 squat took
a big old Armada all over the Indian
Ocean all the way to the east coast of
Africa and there traded freely and and
established a trade economy that is the
Rival of the world
okay for reasons again having to do with
the court not wanting to be um uh
adulterated by foreign influences they
closed off his his uh oops they closed
off his efforts to uh to develop the
trade
here this down here is a map of of
international trade routes and on it are
those places where the Chinese have in
fact made those Investments that I
talked to you about
earlier in terms of
ports damn if they don't look just about
the same now that's because geography is
geography
People Are People goods are goods and
trade is trade and the Chinese
understand it and they are looking to
take advantage of
it so they are prepared to push out into
the world and take what they can fairly
to be sure but take nonetheless and be
able to exert some level of influence
and control that assures them of their
security over time right there is
nothing in the first instance evil about
it but there is is something about it
that is a little disconcerting all right
when you consider that that's the entire
world we're talking about okay and the
Panama Canal under the control of China
or any other foreign power by the way
ought to be a matter of some concern
likewise Suz right likewise The Straits
of
Mala so as a Chinese go through the next
iteration and look to to establish their
control over those places one has to be
attentive and lastly the geography is
enduring I told you they were looking to
build a railroad this is AE SCH atic of
of the ongoing effort the train has
already gone from Chun King all the way
to duberg
Germany and they delivered HP
computers okay and they did it faster
than you can do it by
ship and that uh that train line as I
said earlier has Spurs that run off in
every direction looks like a spider web
okay where the Chinese are looking as
did the Romans to extend their influence
to make others dependent upon them for
their trade and for their politics and
to make it the Chinese as did Rome the
center of the known
universe thank
you well it wasn't quite two hours I
tried I
was I have question
y
yeah
yeah well the the the increase in
spending went has gone on before he got
there the uh percentage increase uh by
him is not greater than it's been in the
past but the base off of which that
percentage is is being uh generated is
much bigger right so he's got A1
trillion do economy where his
predecessor had A3 trillion doll economy
10% of 10 is a lot more than 10% of
three
right so that's the first point second
point is um what's taking place is is
the um the uh police are becoming more
ubiquitous um and and the
pla uh in terms of the the ground
forces uh are are attempting to become a
more professional
Army right um and so that's a little
unsettling in its own right its former
role and and still its constitutional
role by by the way is as the protector
of the Communist party so the the pla is
actually an instrument of the Communist
Party not of the state and so um what
one if if one sees that transition occur
that is that the pla becomes a
instrument of the
state um one ought to see on on uh the
the people's Police become more powerful
and they are you've seen the Coast Guard
become more powerful that Consolidated
peace parts of it okay and so that
civilian agency has become much more
powerful so a lot of the Fisheries
enforcement is taking place by the the
uh Coast Guard not by the uh pla Navy
but on the other hand you ask yourself
the question what is China going to do
with a 1.3 million man
army well let's just go back and read
the 10 campaigns
where were the others fought oh by the
way there were three or four of them in
that other part there three of them I
think further out out there in the west
one up in Mongolia and the remainder
were in Burma and
Vietnam now why is Burma
interesting uh how many of you remember
World War
II what about
Burma so Chinese have built the pipe
pipeline for oil and gas that come
essentially from
rangon um on the Bay of Bengal runs up
along what was the Burma Road up up to
King which is where the B Burma Road
ended
okay um and what does that do um that
places them in a position
flanking
Bangladesh and ultimately India where oh
by the way if you just go around the
corner on the map uh the the uh the
Indians and and the Chinese dispute the
territory which if it goes to the
Chinese leaves them in position to sweep
Down The Valleys of the brahka right
into the plains of
India and if you look down on the other
side uh through what's taking place in
in China's development of things like
the uh uh the makong River delta project
and the dams and all those other
things um they have enormous influence
now down through LA and into Vietnam so
they're on the backside of the
Vietnamese who don't like them very
much so you think back to where we were
in 1979 when China was going to teach
the Vietnamese a lesson right so what
they did in 19 in 2014 is they taught
them a different lesson they put a
multi-billion dollar oil rig off their
coast and said yes you claim this
portion of the sea but you know what
there's nothing you can do about this
there wasn't
right and not two weeks after the
Chinese remove the oil rig who's in
Beijing but the foreign minister looking
for a
deal these things are immutable the only
question is what are the circumstances
under which they come to
pass okay so what's the outcome if the
economy goes bad well some people are
arguing that what we just talked about
is a function of trying to divert
attention inside the country to more
nationalistic activity I don't happen to
think that's right I think the two are
related but but uh not
coincident but we do know what happens
in China when the people become
unhappy right they fought a massive
Civil War over a very long period of
time and millions of people died um
tianan Square shook the foundations of
the regime to its very
core Hong Kong was not a good experience
they managed it much better than they
did um tienan square but Hong Kong isn't
finished the election is still to be
held Taiwan still has an election coming
there is concern about the way in which
things are shaping up in Canton and in
in Shanghai they've cracked down on
gambling in
maau right they're cracking down on
corruption all of this is designed to to
to clamp down on on the the populist to
assure that there isn't an uprising in
my view so this is
anticipatory
yeah
yeah no fair enough I I don't I don't
think my observation that the the proper
preposition is by not of okay so the
Crackdown um so
um corruption is one of those things
which brought down earlier
dynasties when the people are
broadly um unaware of the
corruption the corruption can go
unabated we live in an environment um
where different in the past when they
became attentive to it in China but we
live in this environment where the so
called neens get on Twitter and they
start going on about it right um there
are
653 million Chinese internet
users there are over a billion
smartphones okay these people are
connected to one another they see it
they talk about it they know what's
going on so the party if it's going to
maintain its legitimacy has got to turn
to the people and say
we don't like it
either so cracking down has at least two
benefits uh one is to sustain the
legitimacy of the Party by telling the
people that the party doesn't accept the
corruption of its
own and and it will Purge those who who
abuse the people so please trust us
we're we're looking out after you we've
all heard that one before all right so
so so that that's the first argument the
second argument or the second purpose it
serves is it actually does purge the
people you don't
want okay so so you get a twofer here so
these aren't just show trials to get rid
of certain people because it will play
well they are also people who who belong
to other
factions right some of some of them
belonging to hinau and and the previous
um leadership there and and it helps to
solidify his control now there's one
little mystery which I think is
enormously interesting in light of what
we just said about Burma one of the guys
they got for
corruption has been charged with
supporting the Insurgency inside of
Burma right with Chinese uh
assistance now the reason that's
interesting part is the Burmese now if
you if you saw just recently were
charged by the Chinese
with
bombing
Chinese uh
territory as part of their effort to put
down the
Insurgency taking place in
Burma so here's this curious set of
things happening on the very border we
were just talking about which is
extraordinarily important to China what
does it mean I have got a clue but it's
it but it's wrapped up in uh taking
control of the military rooting out
corruption and assuring the the military
and the party rooting out the corruption
in order to be able to uh maintain your
legitimacy with the people how that all
plays out read the newspapers I mean
it's going to be
fascinating
yeah
y
yep
chines I think it's uh it's um at least
uh moderate to moderately high and
probably on the moderately high side
what's going on uh again as part of
we're looking out for
you uh there has been a massive campaign
against Western monopolistic
practices so
mercedesbenz
BMW
Microsoft
Cisco and there's one
other uh have been uh called out by the
uh you know the Party Committee to
assure fairness for everybody and his
brother but the guy who's doing this who
is the anti-corruption
Zar uh is one of of the president's lead
guys okay so again you get at least a
twoof for here one I'm protecting the
people but secondly what I get is to
extract
concessions with respect to
pricing labor parts sales Kickbacks oh
sorry um uh uh and all of those other
things that go with uh doing business in
China okay so they are setting the stage
for a set of
rules about how business will be done by
Foreign entities in China and they will
be China's
rules don't I don't want to hear
anything about IMF WTO H frck Frack this
is China we do it this way now you agree
don't you monopolies are bad fair
pricing is good and all we're doing is
enforcing those rules in the way we
think they best apply
here but if I were American companies I
would be quite nervous about it they
have decreed for example that all um
computer
servers servicing government accounts uh
will be made in China and they will run
Chinese operating systems and all the
applications that are run on them will
be approved by the Chinese and they want
the source
code
Okay Internet
sovereignty which is what they want
right is all about about making the
rules about how that technology is to be
used inside the country so they are
making new rules and they're making them
right in front of our eyes and they're
doing it with the
intent of preventing there being a um a
loss of control and and therefore of
legitimacy by the party as time goes
on again there's nothing about it that
is inherently
evil except that it's terribly
disruptive
right and and the outcome of it uh could
be quite devastating both for the
Chinese people and everybody
else
yeah yeah you know it's funny uh India
is has nearly the same siiz population
it it's likely to grow um you know the
projections are 5 to seven 9% over this
coming period of time when the Chinese
will be a four five and six they're at a
much lower base as we saw in the other
chart um the the the Indians are um uh
person for
person uh every bit as
entrepreneurial business savvy tech
savvy entrepreneurial you know go down
the
list um what they don't have uh the
benefit of and and I use that word
advisedly
uh is is the kind of um central
government which has for China to this
point Marshall that energy and
controlled that energy in a way that
that that propelled that enormous growth
in
capability my view that's much to the
benefit of the Indians because as time
goes on if they continue to go through
the reform processes and grow in the way
that they seem to be going in 20 years
time they will be much better off than
the Chinese are if if you put the two on
their current trajectories it's just
that it's going to take them 20 years to
to get there and that's going to be
painful it's going to be
painful and
a yeah the
re that this is what you need to avoid
here at Hill yeah yeah but but this is
what you need to avoid this is this is
what's waiting for
you if you don't do what needs to be
done it's a
warning it's a
warning and what do you make of the fact
that very large of weal chines
are places like Vancouver cyp the United
States and Chinese women are flying from
these families are flying to the United
States to have their babies here well uh
there's an old expression money is a
coward all right and what it tells you
is that they look at their their their
own economic conditions and
circumstances as being
inhospitable to their future well-being
so they they feel a coming there is it's
it's it they they the people who are are
profiting from the very things we talked
about uh understand as as one Derek
scissors I think you know this the the
last 10 years the economic growth has
been built on Sand okay well these are
the guys who provided the
sand okay so they get it I mean they
they know that this is a weak uh
fundamentals here and so they're looking
to protect it now the government knows
that so what have they done in Vancouver
in particular they've sent the police
over right to cooperate with The
Vancouver Police to go get these people
who are violating Chinese
law and it wouldn't surprise you to know
that the Vancouver Police have been
cooperating with them right because they
are in fact breaking the
law right so it's it's one of those very
interesting circumstances where um doing
what is lawful may turn out to be you
know unjust
yeah speak a littleit state us
infastructure
trory relative to yeah ours ours uh is
down theirs is
up um percentage numbers uh I think are
not that far
off uh but the uh base on which that
growth is Tak place is much greater over
there um first second uh they're
building um the Chinese are essentially
in Green Fields I mean it's there's
nothing there so they just build the The
Rail
lines um there hasn't been to date uh
environmental concerns uh three gorgees
Dam if we have to build the dam and you
know 100 million people are going to get
drowned it's really too bad I mean we'll
help them get out of there but you know
that's not our problem
um so so they are less concerned about
those things so their their
return for the money they're spending in
terms of track laid or miles of track
laate or roads built or something is
probably higher for each dollar that
they're spending you know we we spent uh
an enormous amount of money uh something
in the neighborhood of $400 billion
dollar is the number in the back of my
head on the US Highway System um you
know the Eisenhower highway system in
50s which is commensurate with what the
kind of money they're spending so it's
not it's not that they are spending in
in uh in excess of need that they're
probably
spending uh in places where they don't
need to where they're not getting the
return that they might get okay uh and
we're not spending
enough right we've got a much older
infrastructure right it's the same thing
with phones I mean why are there so many
uh handsets over there and so few
telephones and people's houses hous well
because they didn't start with
telephones in their houses they started
with telephones in their
hands right so if you start out there um
the ease of modernization going forward
is a lot it's a lot easier isn't
it one last one you all done I wear you
out who's the first one to KN
off
huh Mickey yeah figured figured as much
all right well thank you very much